the miami dolphins got in trouble they
got caught for tampering stripped of
their first round pick in the 2023 draft
and their third round pick in the 2024
draft additionally miami's owner steven
ross is suspended until october 17th and
he's fined 1.5 million dollars vice
chairman bruce beale was also fined 500
000
it's a lot so what happened in 2019 and
2020 the dolphins had contacted tom
brady while he was under contract with
the patriots that's a no-no then they
did it again in 2021 and 2022 when brady
was under contract with the bucks they
also had contact with sean payton's
agent in january about peyton becoming
the dolphin's next head coach except
they did it behind the saints back again
a no-no on top of all of this in brian
flores's racial discrimination lawsuit
he said the dolphins engaged in tanking
in other words they lost so that they
could improve their draft picks for
2020. flores said that ross offered him
100k for every game that they would lose
the nfl found them not guilty of doing
this ross's offer apparently was not
serious i don't know this whole thing is
sketchy